I remember going out on the town when
you were young you're 16 years old or
you were you know 22 when you hit the
town anything could [ __ ] happen brah
a friend pulled up he showed up in a
[ __ ] van he didn't even drive a van
one of his parents drove a van and one
of his parents who were probably were
not super smart let their son a 16 year
old kid take the [ __ ] van to go out
at night
is there any how has that not caught on
to parents don't let your [ __ ] son
take the van a van is just a trap house
on wheels
anything could happen dude if somebody
had a car it was like ah things was
limited you know you could ride around
you could listen to some music you could
put some beers in a trunk you could
smoke a joint right somebody had a
[ __ ] van dude if your friend had a
van burr anything could happen
you could start a small business you
could run a butcher shop in the back of
that [ __ ] son you know what I'm saying
y'all doing 40 miles an hour and [ __ ]
dropping bacon bits out the back in a
van anything could happen in a van
you could start a little family back
there you could run it you could start
an advertising agency back there you
know it's Mad Men back here in the in
the third row dude if you ever had a van
with that third row anything could
happen in a van but I remember you were
young the night the night was thick well
you got out of it you know your friend
picked you up at eight o'clock y'all
rolled out if he was girls he was a
couple of bad [ __ ] rolling out you
know put in your [ __ ] you know put in a
real you know put your strongest tampon
in and hit the town we doing it tonight
Danijela you know you know what I'm
saying
Maria you know what I'm saying huh-huh
Susan huh Tiffany tonight we letting it
all
I'll hang out no bra tonight girl I'm
letting these titties touch the wind man
I missed that being young you every dude
I remember we go out man I remember one
time my buddy picked up in he had a van
he had the longest van you could get if
you ever seen that van it was like for
church right but then every now and then
somebody who wasn't with the church
would get the church van dude that thing
had nine rows I'm saying the eighth row
was just force in the ninth row brother
had usually like a little you know
cooler back there a couple of gets you a
couple of uh you know some juice hitters
some you know Capri Suns you know you
get them Capri Suns and you're just
juicing yourself up just dousing
yourself up with fruit juices in that
ninth row then you jump back over the
seating of that eighth row and sin again
boy you know I'm saying drop your sins
stick in and you had to maybe a lady
back there if he was being real wild you
might have had a little man back there
with you you know and that was it man
that somebody somebody who wasn't with
the church got that church van and
anything could happen dude they have the
fourth row that would that was for
remedial reading they had tutoring going
on in the fourth row the fifth row they
had somebody was usually grilling
cheeses or you know doing grilling
cheese is there somebody hit you with
that small that just that if if I don't
know if you ever eaten a grilling cheese
but they're good you know somebody
something was had a dog back there and
they were talking about you know maybe
they were gonna listen to widespread
panic or something I mean anything that
lost some when somebody got that when
somebody that wasn't with the church got
the church van man a dirty magic could
happen you know I'm saying
dirty [ __ ] magic you know they had
dirt you know the one of the roads there
was somebody doing magic or pretending
they were doing magic but really they
were just trying to touch each you know
just trying to get a little bit of touch
you know a little bit of David David
copping feels you know what I'm saying
oh come back here I'm gonna pull a
rabbit out this hat but then you get
back there and the only thing in that
hat is you know a little bit of regular
[ __ ] you're like oh this this ain't a
rabbit
this ain't a rabbit you know but I'm
gonna let that thing hop around on me
man being young man when you worry man
anything could happen when you were
young and when you had a friend that got
to somebody that wasn't with the church
got that church for him could you
believe a parent much less a parent with
the church first of all what is the
church doin cell in that van back out
into the world what do they think is
gonna happen not every family has 19
children remember that vein of the long
van I'm talking about that thing was
like a 40 cedar you could put two
baseball teams in the van and still have
a couple rows for referees to sit
between them but any man went wild stuff
happen with somebody who wasn't with the
church got a hold of that church van and
they had a boy like that in my town this
beautiful boy named Samson and he would
come pick us up in that church van bro
do one of the windows immediately we
couldn't get it open somebody just
[ __ ] broke that [ __ ] out with a
hammer and we were so full we were in
like the sixth row you couldn't even
hear the glass break in the front and we
were smoking giants in there we was
smoking just American children's Giants
just blowing just huffing huge amounts
of marijuana into our lungs and I'm
talking them horse leg hitters man we
had one boy with us he was so weak he
couldn't even hold up some of the big
Giants we was smoking he couldn't even
hold them he had to hold him with both
arms and then also get one of his legs
up there to hold that junk you know he
had to [ __ ] put up he had a he had to
get two hands and a foot up there to
hold that jaunt up to his mouth and he
was just huh
do people smoking horse legs dude
equestrians
you know I'm saying the kind of joints
that might test positive for raw for
doping for steroids
they've been B horse legs baby just dude
I I remember I got high one time you
know did they pick me up at 8 o'clock I
got so high fell asleep at 8:15 I was
unconscious right but still I was young
man and you could fall you could faint
or pass how you could die when you were
young and you wake back up two hours
later and people are like where you been
like I've been [ __ ] dead in row 6 and
like well come on back man you're like
I'm back now you know this is
reincarnation past that jaunt again and
you get John it up but I remember all
kind of stuff people you know using some
you know making uh you'd have a one row
7 or row 8 somebody making illegal
Footwear anything could happen
you know they had a couple of children
back there with printing presses you
know you know making propaganda Flyers
anything could happen you know the first
or second Road that's where people that
really you know some people were just
looking for a ride hitchhikers everybody
was in that in that that church van when
somebody with the hood that wasn't what
the church got a hold of it you know
you'd have people in in the second row
you die or the third row you'd have
people touching each other's crotches
you know Franco bangin
you know fungal banging each other or
but by the seventh row that if they'd be
raising a child the same people later
that evening it was just you know
anything could happen you get married in
row five you know what I'm saying child
rearing in row seven divorced in row 11
working for the city in row 12 BAM son
you got a whole [ __ ] life going on in
that church van boy thing had 46 rows
dude they had a funeral going on row 39
somebody gone somebody died and this
time died for full time this full time
40 hours a week dead we're not talking
part time but man that was a while that
was a wild that was wild being young
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another
and you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one who he's still just watching me do
this because it's alarming